- All right, hello everyone.
I hope you are having an
amazing time in Vegas.
I know I am.
My name is Natalia Leon.
I'm part of our strategic
partnerships team
here at Salesforce.
And today I'm joined by my colleague, Sid,
who's one of our amazing product managers
for our Data 360 platform at Salesforce,
as well as Bill, who is an
amazing solutions architect
over at AWS.
Today, we're really
excited to share with you
how Salesforce and AWS
are empowering customers
to unlock the full potential of the data
that they already have access to,
to deliver better experiences
and set the right foundation for AI.
So during today's time,
we will walk you through an
overview of the solution.
We'll do a little bit of a deeper dive
into the architecture.
We'll showcase a demo, and
then we'll round it out
with some customer success stories.
As a reminder,
please make sure that you
make any purchasing decisions
based on information that is
publicly readily available
to you.
All right, so before we get technical,
I'd like to just ground
us on a simple truth
that I think we can all
relate to as customers
of all the different companies
that we interact with
and the expectations that come from that.
As a customer, I know myself,
I expect companies that I interact with
to understand who I am,
deliver personalized experiences to me,
and anticipate my needs when
I'm interacting with them.
And so based on those expectations,
customers are really
struggling to deliver that
to their end consumers
because all of their
data tends to be siloed.
I know myself, probably you too,
was hopefully taking advantage
of some of the Black Friday deals
that just happened this past Friday.
And when I was doing shopping,
I caught myself expecting these companies
to really get to know me and
deliver the right offers to me.
And what was once an option for companies
is now really truly essential for them
to be able to unlock their
full value of their data
and deliver those personalized experiences
that we all expect from them.
But this right now is really
challenging for companies.
And the reason for that is because
company's data remains fragmented
across multiple systems,
across multiple formats,
leading to a lot of data silos.
And data silos typically means that
company's data is unreliable for insights.
Besides being unreliable for insights,
the data's actually also
really hard to act upon,
impeding companies to be
able to meet customer needs.
And so because of that, what
we've seen with companies
is that their data tends to be siloed
and they're unable to deliver
these personalized connected experiences
that we expect from them.
Companies that are getting ahead
and are really leading the charge
are differentiated themselves
by providing their customers
with the personalized customer experiences
that we deserve and need.
I found myself on Black Friday,
clicking the checkout button pretty fast
when a company was able to deliver
a personalized offer to me
and even provide shopping assistance
for the pair of shoes that I
wanted on the Black Friday.
So with that, because of that challenge
that we're seeing customers experience,
here at Salesforce, we
have partnered with AWS
to help companies be
able to unify their data
and activate it across
the entire enterprise,
which is what we're gonna
be discussing today.
Additionally, as part of this partnership,
we are also enabling companies
to empower their agents
with the right necessary
models and flexibility
and control that they need to
deliver those AI experiences.
Additionally, we are also
enabling multi-agent ecosystems,
depending on the customer's
technology landscape,
and then of course, providing companies
with end-to-end trust and
compliance along the way.
So with that, I'm gonna
pass it over to Sid,
who's gonna show you how Data 360
makes all of this possible.
- All right.
Oh, let me take the clicker.
So the main topic of the
presentation is zero copy,
and that's what Bill is gonna go over.
But before that, I wanna describe
what Data 360 is to everyone.
So we know that in general,
an organization's data state is home
to many separate but related systems,
data lake houses,
warehouses, message brokers,
CRM, ERP, and a host
of other data products.
But Data 360 is distinct
from those existing systems.
It's not a system of record.
It is not a warehouse.
It is not a lake house, although
it is underpinned by one.
It has a very singular purpose,
and that is to harness, harmonize,
and activate every single
data point in your data state,
whether that data point
was generated a second ago,
whether it was generated decades ago,
whether it is structured,
whether it is unstructured,
towards one of three ends.
First and most importantly,
understand the customer.
Second, to grow faster sales.
And third, to improve
productivity, work faster.
And this is why you
will often hear Data 360
described as Salesforce's
activation engine.
Activate is the most important
of the three verbs that I mentioned.
It is the bedrock of Customer 360,
which is the applications
that you're all familiar with,
Sales Cloud, Service Cloud,
Marketing Cloud, and Company,
as well as Agentforce 360,
which is the agents that dwell
and operate within and across
those distinct applications.
Now, what you see on this slide
are three building blocks of Data 360,
and each one builds on the
previous one in some sense.
The first thing is access
data wherever it resides,
and in the manner that is most well-suited
for the task at hand,
optimizing both for
performance and for economics.
Now, the connectivity
suite is extremely rich,
and I will describe it
in further detail later,
but if I was to summarize it in one word,
that would be optionality.
Now, the keystone or the crown jewel
of the connectivity suite is zero copy,
and that's what Bill is
gonna talk about more.
Now, the second building block
is a very important set of
datasets in your data state,
and those are the ones about the customer.
Now, in any engagement
with a prospective client
or a current client, it makes sense
that the more informed
I am about that client,
the more fruitful that
engagement is gonna be,
and typically, we see
that data about a customer
can be spread across
multiple distinct systems,
and so in Data 360, you can create
that unified profile of a single customer,
and that profile becomes the basic
or the atomic unit of
segment of one personalized
automation, analytics, AI,
across sales, service,
and marketing, and more.
The third building block builds on that,
and that is building
the world for the agent,
so just as every single one of us
has a mental model of the world,
we need to provide the same for an agent
if it is to act effectively.
The agent needs to know
what it can and can't do,
of the things that it can do,
what it should and should not do,
and of the things that it should
do, how should it do them?
And so defining that world,
specifically all the nouns
and verbs for the agent,
is something that takes place in Data 360.
So how does data actually get activated?
The first thing is to connect Data 360
to the different systems
in your data state.
And as I mentioned, the connectivity suite
is incredibly rich.
Structured, semi-structured, unstructured,
real-time, streaming, batched, zero-copy.
There are connectors for databases,
for standalone query engines,
data lake houses, warehouses,
application providers.
Almost everything will be covered
within that very expansive
set of connectors.
And again, zero-copy is the focus,
and we're gonna talk
about that more later.
The second step is to harmonize data.
And this is a verb that is
very often misunderstood.
Harmonization simply means to standardize
across the different schemas
that you have in your data state,
to resolve conflicting identities,
and to construct those unified profiles.
So think of this as creating
a blueprint for your business.
Not the actual datasets that
are in your different systems,
but if you were to identify
all the different objects
that are important,
and how do those objects
relate to one another,
that's what we call the
data model object graph.
And the process of creating
that is harmonization.
So to express it in a different way,
think of harmonization as an abstraction
that allows you to decouple
the development of agents
and applications, functions, and analytics
from the source schemas
in your data state.
It's a translation layer
that you build in Data 360,
and it purely comprises metadata.
And I'll show you an example
of what I mean by that.
Once you've harnessed
and harmonized the data,
the third step is to govern.
And there is a rich,
malleable, auditable framework
for creating policies
to manage permissions,
ensure regulatory compliance,
and different levels of granularity.
At the level of the table, OLS,
at the level of a record, FLS,
and at the level of a column.
Now once the data has been
appropriately governed,
not just for humans and automation,
but also particularly for agents,
it's time to activate the data.
And I'm gonna combine columns
four and five into one.
Now there are many, many
different activation services.
And I'll give you three examples.
The first one harkens
back to Data 360's origins
as a customer data platform.
Segmentation is something
that is a very commonly
used workflow by marketers,
where they segment those
different unified profiles
and then conduct surgical
marketing campaigns.
A different and newer one is
something called Document AI,
where a document, unstructured content,
is brought into Data 360.
It's loaded, it's
chunked, it's vectorized,
and it's analyzed.
And then you can create
data actions that say,
if I detect this text in this document,
I want you to send it to an agent,
because I think it's
pretty straightforward
what needs to happen next in
maybe a contractual process.
But if I don't detect that,
then I want you to hand it off to a human.
And then of course,
there's also predictive AI,
which a lot of times gets
overshadowed by generative AI,
but it's still equally important.
For example, in a call center,
it would be good to know
who is the appropriate team
that I should route a support case to,
based on the knowledge
base that I've created
of support cases that have
been previously closed
and were closed successfully,
optimizing for some metric like CSAT.
That's something that you can
create a predictive model for.
There are many different applications.
Those are just three examples.
But the point is that
the first three steps
form that trusted foundation,
the bedrock that powers
Agent 360 and Customer 360.
It's a model that you define once
and that you can use
throughout your applications
so that the distinct activation surfaces
aren't interpreting your
data state in different ways
when they don't have to.
Now, Agent 4 is setting aside pricing
and setting aside SKUs.
Agent 4 is just built on Data 360.
Architecturally, it is the foundation.
But there are three important reasons
why it's important to go through Data 360.
The first thing is unstructured data.
The unstructured data pipeline
resides entirely in Data 360,
where documents get
loaded, they get chunked,
they get vectorized,
you can imbue them with semantic meeting,
and then you can feed them into
a RAG pipeline for an agent.
And we know that an agent's
quality, its effectiveness,
is always going to be limited
by the quality of data that it's fed.
If the quality of data is low,
we can't expect the agent to perform well.
Setting aside unstructured data,
the second pipeline is structured data,
specifically NL to SQL.
How can I ask an agent to
execute analytical queries,
OLAP queries at scale,
whether it's an interactive
agent with a human,
or whether it's an agent
operating in the background?
Going through Data 360 allows you
to use its native query engine
and execute those queries performantly,
not by constructing SQL, but
by asking questions in English.
The third thing is that
when an agent interacts with a client,
it's important for the
agent to realize and learn
from previous engagements with that client
rather than starting
fresh every single time.
That's what memory for Agentforce does.
It's a tightly governed
construct in Data 360
that ensures continuity from
conversation to conversation.
I'm actually gonna skip this one,
'cause I think we covered it.
So now we're getting into the details
of the connectivity suite.
And at a high level, there
are four different categories.
The first thing that
we'll get out of the way
is the unstructured data pipeline.
I'm not gonna focus more on that,
but that's what I alluded to
with load, chunk, vectorize, index.
Now for structured data,
there are three options.
There's batch ingestion, which
is your standard ETL process,
where data gets copied
into Data 360 periodically.
Then there is the real-time data pipeline,
where data can be pushed into
Data 360 in milliseconds.
And then there is zero copy,
which is accessing data at
runtime, as and when needed,
and never persisting external data.
Now, one thing I wanna clarify
is that there is often confusion
between real-time and zero copy,
because zero copy is
described as real-time.
The real-time pipeline in Data 360
is underpinned by a very specific object.
That's called a real-time data graph.
A real-time data graph is effectively
a materialized, denormalized view.
The data gets materialized
inside of Data 360.
Think of this as web engagement data
that is brought into Data 360,
and is used to personalize experience
as a client is browsing a website.
The data is pushed into Data 360.
This is different from zero copy,
where the data isn't pushed.
It is requested precisely
when you launch a workflow
that requires external data.
So what is Data 360 zero copy exactly?
Now, typically, let's say you have
massive business-critical
datasets in a data warehouse.
For zero copy, you would have
to duplicate those wholesale
into the system that you want
to activate that data in.
And any time you have two copies
outside of some tightly
distributed system,
one of those copies is
gonna be behind the other.
That's just physics.
And for some workflows, that's okay.
But for many workflows,
it's not okay to operate
on a stale snapshot.
And that's assuming that the organization
even allows you to duplicate
data in the first place.
And many of our clients will outright say,
"No, I am not willing to move
data out of my data warehouse.
"It is managed by a
specific line of business,
"and in order to activate
it, you must do so at rest.
"I won't have two copies."
So the thesis is very simple.
Securely access the data at runtime.
Your workflows always are powered,
and your agents are
powered by the latest data,
because there is only ever one copy,
and that is the singular external copy.
So fundamentally, this is
about maximizing the value
of the investments that
you've already made
in different data products.
Now, Data 360 copy is
absolutely the keystone
of the connectivity suite.
But the biggest testament I can give you
to how important it's been
is that since 2024, its inception,
it now powers over 50% of the traffic
that comes into Data 360.
The overwhelming majority of our clients
strongly rely on zero copy to access data
from their lake houses
and their warehouses.
And someone asked a good question.
Is that because of an outlier?
Is it one tenant that went wild,
or was it one query that was misfired?
And the answer is no.
The number of tenants that use zero copy
has grown steadily quarter over quarter,
and their footprint and
the workloads that they run
have also increased in
size quarter over quarter.
And so what we're gonna
focus on next in detail
is the zero copy suite with AWS.
And we'll talk about
the different patterns,
the different connectors
that are available,
and we'll show you a short demonstration.
So with that, I'll hand it over to Bill.
- Great.
So we've heard a little
bit about partnership,
and we've heard a little
bit about what it means
to do Data 360 in terms of Salesforce.
Hopefully, most of you
here are joint customers
of AWS and Salesforce already.
And this is really where
the magic starts to happen
in terms of what we create.
Because one of the things I've noticed
ever since I started working
with Salesforce as an AWS SA
is one of the primary
things we have in common
is one of the leadership
principles of customer obsession.
So when we listen to our
customers and they come to us
and tell us that they have specific things
they wanna do with their data,
we work with them to try
to create those mechanisms.
And I think that's
reflected on this slide,
which isn't just a slide
of the current state,
but also of the roadmap of what
we're building out together
to make it easier for our
customers to have data freedom,
to be able to put their
data where they need it.
And as you've already heard, as Sid said,
in this new agentic world,
your data has to be more fluid.
It has to move to where you're running
your agentic workloads.
So let me talk about a customer example.
So we'll walk you through
these different things
on the slide in just a second,
but I was working with a
FinTech customer earlier this year.
Really great customer, loves Salesforce,
has a bunch of different
Salesforce products,
including Marketing Cloud, Data Cloud,
using Agentforce, big fans,
love what they're doing.
And so over time, their suite
of how they've integrated
between their AWS estate
and Salesforce has evolved.
Of course, they came to
us with RDMS databases.
They had RDS in place,
and they wanted to pull
that data into Salesforce.
So RDGA now, we had built
what we call Query Foundation.
And as you can see from the slide,
it exposes several different AWS services,
including Athena, RDS, Aurora, and more,
as traditional data sources.
Now, when I say a traditional data source,
picture this if you're a programmer
or if you've seen
applications working before.
It's simply a call out to the database.
It does a query and it
returns values to you.
We'll dig into a little
bit of what that means
on the next slide.
But for the purpose of this customer,
it did what they needed.
They were able to query their data,
bring it into Salesforce,
combine the data,
and everything was good.
Well, now fast forward a couple years.
Now we're in 2025, and most
companies have data lakes.
And data lakes take us into a
different set of AWS services.
We're no longer talking
about our traditional RDMSs.
We're talking about the flat
file systems like S3 and Glue.
So now they have these estates of data,
and their question to us was,
how do we now take this data
and make it available to Salesforce?
So we wanna use Customer 360.
We're doing marketing campaigns.
We're pulling in data from all
sorts of different sources.
We would like to bring
those into Salesforce
where we have our
customer source of record,
use Customer 360 to identify
all of those unique customers
who we're actually gonna reach out to
so we're not wasting a
bunch of our marketing time.
So the process that they
went through with us
was starting with File Federation.
And as you can see, File Federation
is actually in beta right now,
and it's gonna be GA in February.
So they're already on board.
They're starting to build this out now.
And they're taking their data lake
and exposing it over to Salesforce.
The plan is to make this available,
to let them create customer records.
But now the interesting part.
It's really not enough just to
have that data in Salesforce.
So think about the sort of trade-offs
between AWS and Salesforce
in terms of the roles
who are consuming Salesforce and AWS.
Most of the people you talk to
who are actually logging
into an AWS console,
they're techs, right?
They're geeks like me.
People who log into the console,
they're willing to go
through these experiences.
I generally don't expect the
business users on my team
to come into that AWS console,
at least not frequently.
On the other hand, while
I am a Salesforce user,
I don't expect to do a
business person's job
in terms of running queries
and marketing campaigns
and everything else.
I wanna unlock those capabilities for them
so they don't make me do it.
So in a nutshell, for this customer,
they didn't just wanna bring
that data back into Salesforce.
They wanted to round trip
it back to AWS as well.
So this is the third column
we have here, data sharing.
In a lot of ways, when
we get into the details
about what file federation
and data sharing mean,
they're actually kind of the same thing
in opposite direction.
We're unlocking bi-directional copy.
For this customer, they wanted to create
these customer 360 records,
copy them back to AWS
so they can again enrich their data lake,
take all of that data
that they've collected
and make their AWS estate
of data more effective.
So this bi-directional copy
really was gonna enable
everything that they wanna do.
And you can see a few
different services on here.
So this is already GA now.
You see EMR, you see Redshift,
you see Athena on here.
All of these provide AWS capabilities
for the other end of this.
Basically, if you think of
this on the Salesforce side
as Glue feeding data back
into these AWS services,
you'd be pretty much correct.
So Glue kind of in both directions,
allowing us to access data
catalogs with Iceberg.
And I'll get a little bit more
into the technical details
in a couple slides.
But using Iceberg data catalogs
to allow us to expose the data
and without having the same
type of copy and query,
which I'll get to in a second,
we're gonna be able access to Iceberg data
and we're gonna enable us to have
an interesting time sequence
where we can get to that data frequently
and less and more easily.
And as we'll see on the next slide here,
with a number of different advantages.
So Query Federation, by the way,
I'm not bad mouthing Query
Federation, it's great.
If you need access to
your traditional databases
and you wanna bring that
data into Salesforce,
that remains absolutely valuable.
Not going away, we're gonna support that
as long as you guys keep
buying databases from us.
On the other side though,
there are some real
advantages of File Federation.
And the very first line up here
describes one of the main advantages.
I'm an old programmer, I
programmed for a long time.
JDBC drivers were something we did in Java
back in the day, right?
It's been around 20, 30 years,
however long it's been since
we actually invented Java.
I guess I should know since James Gosselin
actually works for AWS now.
But JDBC drivers simply provide
you a pipe to go get data.
You say, hey, I'm gonna run the SQL query,
SQL engine, you execute this
for me, return some data.
It's always worked the same way.
It works the same way here.
We're outsourcing the
query to the engine itself
and saying, you just
give me back the data.
Every time I want that data,
I hand the same query over,
it hands me back a pile of data.
The Iceberg Catalog capabilities
that come with File Federation
are entirely different.
Because Iceberg is a catalog,
it allows us to, over time,
create what we would
call change data flows,
where we can actually say, hey,
I'm gonna pull this data in,
but I'm gonna keep a sort
of a cached copy of it
because I have access to the catalog.
Now, instead of making real-time queries
and every time saying,
hey, give me all the data,
give me all the data,
I can create these change data sets
and say, what has actually changed?
And now, because this is
running on the Salesforce side
and the queries are running in Data 360,
I don't have to be going
back to that query engine
every time and pulling
back all of that data.
I actually know what has changed
since the last time I called
it because of Iceberg.
And this is a neat part
of the capability, right?
It allows us to take the change data feed,
understand exactly what's coming
in, what's come in before,
and it makes it faster and more efficient.
And because it's Iceberg on the AWS side,
it's also a lot more
cost efficient, right?
So you can keep your files
in S3, you can use Glue,
and this unlocks a lot of
interesting cost advantages.
And in addition, on the cost side,
if you're doing query federation,
as you can see on line number five there,
you can actually see you're
paying twice for this data.
You're paying to query
it, you're paying us
to query it in Athena,
if your data's in Athena,
and then you're paying for
the Data 360 side of that.
That's different with
file federation as well.
You're really just paying for
the Data 360 side of this,
and you're not worrying about
having to pay the AWS side
other than what you're already
paying us for your data lake.
So it's actually a really nice advantage.
There's another nice advantage
that I don't wanna overlook,
and that's parallelization.
Parallelization. (laughs)
When we are talking about how
we get the data back over,
this is an operation that allows us
from the Data 360 side to actually run up
multiple versions of the query.
Remember how I said JDBC is
like a single pipe, right?
I can only have a single
query however long that takes,
however long it takes
it to stream back up.
I can actually do
parallelization on Data 360
with file federation specifically
because we have data file level push down,
we have partition level pruning,
and data file level pruning.
And all of those unlock parallelization
in the native query engine
that they built from scratch
inside of Data 360.
So instead of relying on
our old school query engines
that live on the other side,
they built an entirely new query engine
that lives in Data 360 and unlocks a lot
of great capabilities that
you'll wanna take advantage
if you're building.
So if you're in any way
thinking about a data lake,
if you're thinking about
building a data lake,
remember that these capabilities
that we're creating today
are gonna unlock these business use cases
that go back, going back to my customer,
enable them to do specific
business functions
honestly they wouldn't have
been able to do otherwise.
So it's pretty cool.
It adds a lot of new capabilities.
And there's other things on here
that are a little bit different.
You can do more files, bigger file sizes
and more files with file federation.
A lot of those details are
important for specific cases.
But really, I want you
to focus on the fact
that you're using different
types of services, right?
Traditional data sources
versus data lakes.
And that the iceberg allows us
to keep a changed data set over time
so that we're not having to reach back
and pull back all of the
data every time we query.
Pretty cool functionality and
I'm pretty excited about it.
Let me bring up a slide
that kind of hopefully
brings a lot of this together.
I know I'm throwing a lot
of sort of different angles
on this, but remember how I said
the data is flowing in
and it's flowing out.
This particular slide is
designed to sort of show you
how these different pieces fit in.
In your AWS customer account,
again, you might have your databases,
you've got your data
lakes, got S3, S3 tables,
all of those different
data estate resources
that are available to you.
Well, Query Federation and File Federation
are sitting there as pipes to
bring your data into Data 360.
So you can see there,
we've got JDBC on there
and then we have table scans,
which again, implies Iceberg.
And you can see on the Data 360 side,
if you look a couple
things down from Data 360,
Iceberg tables, so Data
360 is also operating
on Iceberg tables.
In terms of what we're
actually working from,
my customer use case, in their case,
they were trying to unlock
some business solutions
around marketing, but this
is important for AI agents.
You could take the same
scenario with a customer
and talk about how they wanna
run agents on both sides.
They wanna run agent
force and execute agents
against their customer data in Salesforce.
Maybe they wanna run agent
core over on the AWS side
and run that against their AWS data.
Unlocking this data flow bidirectionally
allows more agentic AI
flows to come to life.
And of course, analytics and
the traditional ad platforms,
AI/ML platforms,
all of those are unlocked
by this data flow.
Finally, at the bottom of
this, I wanna call out,
remember, this is bidirectional.
You can see that we actually
show a Glue data catalog,
exposing this back into AWS.
And again, I said that file federation
and the data access going back,
it's almost the same
thing just in reverse.
Both sides are using Iceberg,
both sides are using Glue,
and in fact, both sides are also using
something called Lake Formation.
Lake Formation allows us to
do fine-grained permissioning
on data sources in AWS.
Some of you may already
be familiar with it.
If you're doing data lakes,
you might already be using this
to apply permissions to your database.
So as you can see,
it can apply to a number
of different sources.
We often see it come up, of course,
with our data lake function,
with our data lake functions,
and I think that's kind
of the key word there.
It is a lake formation, right?
But you can also use it with
a number of different sources
as you're pulling them
into your data lake.
Now that fine-grained access control
is particularly important
when we're talking about file federation.
If you've ever done any sort
of remote work with AWS,
one of the ways that
you can provide access
to something remotely is to
take long-lived credentials
and copy them over there.
It's not really considered
a great practice to do that.
I know you can find lots of
resources out there saying,
hey, just get your key and your secret
and copy it over here
and store it somewhere.
It's kind of sad because there
was plenty of documentation
saying to do that for years.
But if you're doing anything today,
if you can find a way to take advantage
of short-lived credentials, please do.
And this means IAM roles,
and in this case, it means
using lake formation.
Lake formation allows us to
vend short-term credentials
from Data 360, so we don't have to keep
those long-term credentials
on the Data 360 side
specifically for file federation.
And in fact, it's using
SIGV4 in this case.
So if you wanna understand
how this actually works,
you can kind of dig into it.
We're taking SIGV4, we're
copying that over into Data 360,
and that gives it API access
over to AWS through Glue.
So this is actually an
important piece of the solution.
And if you remember
nothing else out of that,
that short-term vending credentials,
that's really what unlocks better security
for this file federation flow.
I'm gonna end right before we go back
and show a little bit of a demo of this.
Talking a little bit about Glue,
hopefully you've kind of
gotten a high-level visual.
Glue allows us to do
Apache Iceberg, right?
Apache Iceberg, if you
haven't worked with it before,
allows you to take simple objects in S3
and turn 'em into tables.
It sounds a little crazy.
How do you just take a bunch of files
and turn 'em into tables?
Well, it actually can
extract out a catalog
that describes the data and also,
going back to the changed data
follow we were talking about,
captures what that data
state is over time.
This is really where
Glue is pretty magical.
And Glue does a little bit more than this.
There's a couple things
I'd really wanna call out.
You don't have to remember
all of these things,
but it's serverless.
Increasingly with AWS,
if you can find a way
to take advantage of serverless function
and not have to manage
compute on your own behalf,
please do.
This is the way a lot of things are going.
If you're looking at Agent Core,
it looks very similar, right?
Manage services that are serverless
and you don't have to manage the overhead.
It's got great durability.
Because this is backed by S3,
all of the same types of functionality
in terms of durability,
availability, scalability
that you're relying on in
the underlying S3 instances
also start to emerge in Glue as well.
It integrates with all
sorts of different catalogs
and of course, it provides through Athena
additional querying in terms
of getting to your data.
With that, I think we've
effectively covered
most of the stuff here
around the AWS side,
but I do wanna hand it back to Sid
and we're gonna walk you
through what this looks like.
Hopefully the internet holds up
and we'll show it to you live.
If not, we actually have
a bit of a recorded demo.
Hopefully we won't need
to fall back on that.
Thanks, Sid.
- Thanks, Bill.
Okay, so there is an actual booth
where there is a
full-fledged end-to-end demo
and that's not what we're gonna show here.
We'll just touch on a couple of components
of what Bill described
so that we can put some
pictures and actual components
to the different things
that we talked about.
So, this is Data 360's setup
and it's where you
configure the connections
to the different systems in AWS.
And let's take a look at a couple of them
because there are many
different AWS services
that we can connect to.
So, as Bill mentioned, we span
query engines such as Athena.
They're your traditional
relational databases
such as Aurora MySQL and the
corresponding RDS flavors.
There's also Amazon Redshift.
This is a query federation connection.
And then there's AWS Glue.
And so, I wanna briefly
clarify again one more thing
with query federation just to emphasize.
It's a single-threaded connection
to an external warehouse.
And even though Data 360
will try to push down
as many operators as possible,
we're ultimately limited
to that single thread.
And that's something that is
not true with file federation
and is very important when it comes
to massive volumes of data,
which is typically what clients
use Data 360 to execute.
So, let's take a look
at the file federation connector for Glue,
which is currently
offered as a beta feature.
Now, as Bill mentioned,
there are two services
when it comes to an
iceberg data lake house.
There is the metadata catalog,
which is in this case Glue,
and the underlying object storage bucket,
which is in this case S3.
Now here, you'll see that you
have to provide an access key
and a secret access key, which
correspond to the IAM user
that has been given the
appropriate permissions
to communicate only with the catalog.
Nothing long-lived related to storage
needs to be given to Data 360,
which is a security best practice.
And that's because Glue will
vend temporary credentials,
as Bill mentioned, at runtime.
When the workflow terminates,
the external data is forgotten,
and so too are the
temporary S3 credentials.
So, I have a couple of
different connections
already configured to
Redshift, Query Federation,
S3, Batch Ingestion, and Glue,
which is File Federation.
Let's enter Data 360
the application proper.
We'll exit Setup.
So here are a couple
different data streams.
Now, a data stream is
nothing more than a link
between Data 360 and a
specific external table.
It captures metadata,
particularly what are the columns
that you want to project into Data 360.
So, let's take a look at what happens
when I try to create one for AWS Glue.
I'll select the connection,
and what happens here is we
query the metadata catalog
to understand the objects
that are exposed to Data 360.
The database picklist corresponds
to the different namespaces
that you've configured
in your Iceberg Glue catalog.
Now, in this case, the
Schemas menu is empty,
but if each one of these
namespaces, in turn,
had a namespace, they would
be displayed over there
because the specification for Iceberg
allows for arbitrarily deep namespaces.
These are the different
objects that are available,
so let's see one of those in action.
Now, there are a variety
of different applications,
but it's not easy to demonstrate zero copy
in a way that is visually illustrative,
so I'm gonna take the simplest of them,
which is Query Editor,
and then we'll take a look at a CRM object
that brings data in real time from AWS.
So, in Query Editor,
and this is just firing
a simple SQL query,
I'm gonna select the Glue object,
and we'll just run a query.
We'll bump up the...
And what happens here is we
fetch the data at runtime.
Now, this looks really simple, right?
It wasn't something crazy,
but the point is that
we query the catalog,
we get the metadata, we
parallelize execution,
and when I close the tab,
the data is forgotten.
So, let's take a look at something
that is a little bit more practical,
and we'll enter an
application, a CRM application,
so one of the Customer 360 apps.
Click on the contact record.
Now, let's imagine that this is a resort,
and they're bringing
in data from Redshift,
and they're bringing in data from Glue,
and they want that contact record
to display information
relevant to the customer
that resides in those two systems,
and these are displayed as related lists.
So, I'll click on Sofia Rodriguez,
and let's go to related,
and this is where the data
doesn't live in Data 360,
it's gonna be fetched once I go here.
So, if I refresh the
tab, refresh here too,
this is the data that is coming
from Redshift and from Glue,
so it's not stored over here.
Now, how exactly did this happen?
Let's go back to Data Cloud,
and I will show you an
example of what I mean
by that blueprint that we talked about
with all the nouns and verbs.
I'm gonna switch to graph view,
and so what I have here
are the different objects
that are important to my business.
The first thing is an individual.
That has a relationship with reservations,
which are stored in Redshift,
and many other different objects,
but the important thing to understand
is that not every one of these
is an actual table in Data 360.
It's just a pointer to something in AWS.
Metadata is something that pops up
in almost every Salesforce presentation,
but this is what we mean by that.
We're just capturing information
about how you have structured
your data state externally.
Now, the last thing that I wanna show
is identity resolution.
Now, this is one specific
example of resolving information
about the same customer that
resides in different datasets.
Now, some of this information
came from Redshift,
the guest data, and some
of it came from CRM,
the existing contacts,
and you won't actually see
zero copy in action here,
but notice on the right
side the consolidation rate.
That means that you had
multiple records in AWS
and multiple records in CRM,
but they weren't all
describing distinct clients.
They were describing, in
many cases, the same person,
and that's reflected in
the consolidation rate,
saying that it turns out
that we only had 50 customers
and not 100,
and that's how you're able
to get that unified profile
in CRM, which is the
contact that I showed you.
Now, like I said, there's a
full-fledged demo at a booth,
but before I go, there's one
more thing that I wanna show
to clarify what Bill said
about changed data feeds,
because that's something very important.
Now, let's take a look at
something called a data action.
I'm gonna create one manually.
Let's see, I don't have
a data action target.
Okay, let's see if I created one.
All right, while this loads,
I'll explain it verbally,
but the point is that a
data action target relies on
it's a trigger that says
when a record gets created,
I want you to go do something.
When it gets deleted, I
want you to go do something.
Now, in Query Federation,
if you think about it conceptually,
there's no way to detect
that something changed
in an external table,
because all I ever see is
the most recent version,
and to determine if something changed,
I need to have a historical record
of how the table evolved over time,
but with Query Federation,
you can do things like data actions,
because the Iceberg
Catalog glue in this case
gives us different snapshots
for the same object.
So you say, if something
happened to my insurance table,
I want you to go take an action,
and with File Federation,
you don't have to copy
that table into Data 360.
The second benefit is performance.
For many workflows like segmentation
and identity resolution,
with Query Federation,
you're operating on the entire
table every single time,
but with File Federation,
you're only operating on the increment,
and that's because we can calculate
what that increment is by
looking at the Metadata Catalog.
That results in both higher performance,
and it results in lower costs.
So these are the
different building blocks.
I think that's pretty much
what we wanted to show.
And Q&A, or customer stories, yes.
- Awesome.
Great, well, thanks, Sid.
I think I would wanna stay
at Coral Cloud Resorts,
given that it sounds like they know how to
understand their customers,
have a full picture of their customers,
and be able to deliver
personalized experiences.
But of course, that was
a fictional scenario,
so we did actually want
to share with you guys
the results that customers
are already seeing
from taking advantage of this solution.
So 1-800-ACCOUNT is a great
example of a customer.
They are an accounting services firm
who helps small businesses
with all of their accounting needs.
And I recently had the pleasure
of talking to their CTO,
who was telling me that previously,
their data was siloed
across multiple systems.
They had Salesforce, they had Data Lake,
they had custom tax software systems.
And during the tax season,
that was really tough for them,
because their client advisors
were spending a lot of time
managing customer inquiries
with data scattered all
around their systems.
And so they decided
that they really needed
to scale their workforce
to be able to support their customers,
and they leveraged Zero Copy
to unify all of their different
systems that they had,
and allowed their client advisors
to actually be able to focus
on high-value conversations
with their customers.
They deployed AI agents
that were able to answer
70% of the administrative questions
that customers were
asking on a regular basis,
and really allowed their client advisors
to be more scalable for their workforce.
Additionally, another great
story was Buyer's Edge.
They are a procurement company
that helps in the food industry,
and they actually were able
to unify 20-plus different
systems together,
to again, be able to
create that unified view
of their customers and
be able to deliver them
with the right personalized offers.
So with that, I hope
you're inspired by the demo
and all these different customer stories.
Like Sid said, we have a
great, more in-depth demo
available at our Salesforce booth
and experts that would be really happy
to talk to you guys about this.
Additionally, you can scan this QR code
to learn more about our partnership.
And as always, feel free to contact
your Salesforce account team.
Awesome.
Thank you so much for your time.
We really appreciate it and, yeah.